oh amazing all right cool all right well
we're delighted to have cardiff
uh the second uh
session
okay hi i'm fred i'm a postdoc at the
simon institute for this fall and i'll
be at stanford as a postdoc after that
i thought i'll talk about something
related to the ccsi program so this is
about sparse linear regression it's a
classical problem with conjectured
computational statistical gaps
okay first of all i gotta remind you
maybe that sparse linear aggression is
kind of like a whole field actually so
and it has a lot of different
applications and there are also
different ways to set up the problem
so i'm gonna focus on uh on a very
specific way to set up the problem which
is a gaussian random design model
and it's a it's kind of a learning
problem so i give you samples of the
form x i y i
and your goal is to learn how to predict
y from x
and the x samples they're from a
gaussian let's say was arbitrary
covariance matrix sigma
and the y samples are just a linear
function of the x and you
generally add some noise which we'll
also say for simplicity is gaussian
though that doesn't really matter if
it's gaussian noise or some other noise
so the goal is to learn how to predict y
from x uh for like a fresh sample x
that's the usual goal in i guess
learning and
it turns out to be equivalent to
minimizing this thing called the
mahalanobis norm and
it's just defined at the bottom it's
it's like the l2 norm but you put a
sigma in
and this problem has actually very
simple behavior statistically uh so for
any covariance matrix sigma
the information integrate is this it's a
sigma in the mahlenov's norm you get
sigma squared k log d over n
okay so that's that's some expression
the important thing is that it
essentially does not depend on the
dimension so if you have a very sparse
vector uh
you know you're going to get a way
better sample complexity by having this
sigma squared k over n versus if you do
ordinary least squares you'll have sigma
squared d over n
and so that's really the game is when
you're sparse you're trying to take
advantage of that to basically save your
samples um
so this is a really great physical
guarantee but it's not computationally
efficient so the estimator which
achieves this is called best subset
selection
it searches over all sets of size k
that could be the possible support so it
requires d to the k runtime
so we basically you know sometimes
people try to run this algorithm but
what's the approach we really like to
use is the lasso
so lasso is this thing i wrote it's just
it's like ordinarily squares you try to
minimize the square loss but then also
put in this l1 penalty and then there's
this whole idea that the l1 penalty on
the w is going to try to encourage
sparsity
in some sense
and after a long line of work we know
actually uh very good guarantees for
lasso and we know that if the condition
number of sigma so like lambda max over
lambda min
if that's a constant then lasso actually
achieves the optimal performance up to
constants
so that's great
but it kind of leaves us with this
picture right because we know that the
problem is actually statistically
possible just for any sigma
then when the condition number is
constant we can solve it with lasso then
there's also okay people worked very
hard to generalize that so there's a
technique called weak super modularity
which can extend a set of sigma a little
bit beyond that and there's also
different notions of what a
well-conditioned matrix is
but basically the picture is we can
solve it for the well-conditioned ones
and we don't know what happens for the
general sigma
okay then a very important related line
of work is people have studied empty
hardness
but if you kind of know about this kind
of problem you generally only expect to
get mp hardness for a worst case
setup so whereas basically instead of
galaxy and xi i get a worst case choice
of xi
and so this is the kind of thing that
actually pulling little talked about in
the workshop or sorry in the boot camp
like a couple weeks ago
okay so yeah we don't really know in
this setup what happens for general
sigma
and that's what we like to try to
understand better so in this work we
sort of give a new set of covariance
matrices which you can solve and maybe
give some suggestion for what kind of
covariance matrices you can't solve
it turns out the key definition that's
going to be relevant is
is this graph which is related to the
galaxy
so how do you get this graph you just
invert the covariance matrix sigma you
get this thing called theta which is the
precision matrix
and you just take the support of that
and that gives you a graph where it's a
you know where you have n coordinates
those are the vertices and you have an
edge whenever there's a non-zero entry
in this matrix
and you know i'm not going to belabor
this point but this encodes something
called the markov property
um so like this graph will be sparse in
a lot of situations like if you have a
simple causal model that generates for
data
so we care a lot about this graph for
various reasons
what can we say in terms of this graph
well actually it turns out we can get
this whole new set of
covariance matrices where sparse linear
regression is possible uh
computationally efficiently
so if the graph has a low tree wave
which you know is one of our favorite
complexity parameters for tree lifts for
graphs
uh it actually has bounded through us we
get the information there to optimal
performance and it you know it degrades
naturally as a tree which gets larger
the algorithm well we know we lasso is
really good for this kind of problem
it's not so good if it's ill-conditioned
so we do some kind of pre-conditioning
i won't tell you how the pre-conditioner
is constructed but if you know about
tree waste there's this classical idea
called nested dissection and that's
basically how we construct the
pre-conditioner and it can be done
without actually knowledge of sigma you
just need to know the graph
so okay so that's good so we have a new
set of sigma for which we can solve the
problem which was not known before
but another important
theorem i think in this paper is kind of
a matching lower bound so what happened
is we don't really know maybe what kind
of sigma are really the hard ones if any
for this problem
but for this uh this algorithm the
preconditions lasso where basically i
change basis and run lasso we now know
like there are some examples where it
just cannot work no matter what
preconditioner you pick
basically you get very poor performance
compared to that substitute selection
so i won't belabor the technical
statement but you can see it there
basically it says when you have polylog
sparsity and polylog samples you can
exactly recover in the noiseless setting
but if you run preconditional assets
with any pre-conditioner you get uh you
do not get exact recovery and you get
which means you're basically infinitely
worse than what you should be getting
so we know yeah if we just look at graph
structure actually true waste just
totally characterizes when
preconditioned lasso can and cannot work
and that's a very natural algorithmic
approach lasso is our favorite approach
basically to solve sparse and regression
so it's possible that these covariance
matrices are hard for all polynomial
time algorithms but yeah we just don't
know
okay and just as an example like okay
kochinski and minsker studied the case
where sigma basically comes from a
simple random walk
they study the performance of lasso for
this problem which uh depending on how
exactly you do it it's either there's a
blue or a red line
and it's just an example if you're
pre-conditioned you'll do way way better
and you can prove that lasso requires
like square root
basically lasso like requires square
dimension samples and uh if your
precondition you only require the
information
like log d samples so it's you know
something you can easily see in
experiments
okay so like i said it's an open problem
to understand exactly what's going on
for sparse linear regression for
arbitrary sigma
we gave some evidence it could be hard
but you could also try to
provide other evidence or find other
classes that are solvable
a very closely related problem is
learning gaussian graphical models when
you don't have a condition number
assumption
uh the techniques that we have developed
for that are
both related and different so i won't
say anything about that but there's also
several other uh open problems related
to this actually gus and capcom model
stuff
so that's all i want to say about this
uh
topic
but there are several related toxic
topics i'm interested in and i would
love to talk to you about so i work also
on mixing time of markov chains
i've worked on robust statistics of
course i worked on many things related
to graphical models uh i worked on the
nine overfittings so yeah i would be
happy to talk about any of those kinds
of things thanks
yeah i mean i think like people have
found examples where lasso doesn't work
before
then we have showed examples where
pre-conditioned last doesn't work but if
you're saying like sq a lower bound or
something is not known
but like was this model
yeah i think that's not entirely trivial
yeah so that's a good question but
yeah i think basically in sq you can
implement lasso i'm not so sure about
low degree polynomials
yeah yeah exactly so there's a way to
just from the samples you form an
empirical covariance and it's
based on that it's a little tricky but
you can construct the pre-conditioner
good